- [Rehab Worker] Hi Klaus
(soft violin music)
(package slams)
We'll see you soon Klause
(coin dings)
Stay sober!
- I could've, cleared my schedule.
(laughs at self)
Sober up!
(face slapping)
Come on!
It's so,
(items crash)
touching, all that stuff
about family, and dad,
time--
(swing music)
(grunts)
(sirens in distance)
(instrumental rock music)
(breathes in)
(sighs)
(shouts out)
- Klaus, what are you doin' in here?
- Oh, Allison,
Ah!
Number three, get out of his chair.
(laughs)
(swings and hits)
Hit him!
It's just like old times,
(rain falling)
best funeral ever.
- [Allison] Is that my skirt?
- What? Oh yeah, this,
I found it in your room,
it's a little dated, I know,
but it's very breathe-y
on the bits.
- Listen up.
- (gurgling) Oh! Quelle surprise!
- I know you don't like
to do it, but I need
you to talk to dad.
(snorts)
I can't just call dad in
the afterlife and be like
"Dad, could you just
stop playing tennis with
Hitler for a moment
and take a quick call?"
- Since when, that's your thing?
- I'm not in the right frame of mind.
- You're high?
- (laughs) Yeah!
Yeah, I mean, how are you not?
Listening to this nonsense?
(laughs) Manifesting!
Come on, chop chop!
You always were a stubborn bastard!
I don't know about you,
but I need a drink.
(crashes)
(laughs) Oh, oh.
("Sinnerman" by Nina Simone)
(men shouting)
(guns fire)
♪ Oh, sinnerman, where you gonna run to ♪
♪ Sinnerman where you gonna run to ♪
- I'm going out there.
♪ Where you gonna run to ♪
♪ All on that day ♪
♪ Will I run to the rock ♪
♪ Please hide me, I run to the rock ♪
♪ Please hide me, run to the rock ♪
(guns firing)
♪ Please hide me lord ♪
♪ All on that day ♪
♪ But the rock cried out ♪
♪ I can't hide you, the rock cried out ♪
(muffled screaming)
(muffled talking)
- [Man in Suit] What's he saying
(duct tape rips)
- Oh.
- [Woman In Suit] What are you saying?
- You guys are scarier without the masks.
(smacking)
No, no.
(door slams)
(suspenseful music rises)
(grunts)
(sighs)
(laughs)
(locks open)
("Mary" by Big Thief)
♪ Burn up with the water ♪
♪ The floods are on the plains ♪
♪ The planets in a rose ♪
♪ Who knows what they contain ♪
♪ And my brain is like an orchestra ♪
♪ Playing on, insane ♪
♪ Will you love me like you
loved me in the January rain ♪
- [Klaus Narrating] His name was Dave.
- Yeah shit's crazy, I know.
- Yeah.
- You'll adjust.
I'm Dave.
- Klaus.
- [Klaus Narrating] We soldiered together
in the A Shau Valley
in the Mountain of the Crouching Beast.
(guns fire)
- Medic!
Medic!
Dave!
Look at me, look at me!
Oh Damnit.
Medic!
Look at me, look at me, hey hey hey.
Hey, hey, it's okay, hey, hey.
Please stay with me Dave, please, please.
No, no no no no no no.
Oh, my god, hi Dave,
it worked,
Dave.
What happened here?
- You look like shit.
- Oh why thank you, hey where you going?
- Nope.
- What?
- I'm not giving you a ride.
- Come on, man, you know I can't drive.
- I don't--
("Happy Together" by The Turtles)
- Okay, great, I'll just
get my things, two minutes.
(gunshots)
(grunts)
See?
You used to think I was an idiot.
- I still think you're an idiot.
Go faster!
(gunshots)
♪ and ease my mind ♪
♪ Imagine how the world
could be, so very fine ♪
♪ So happy together ♪
♪ I can't see me lovin' nobody but you ♪
♪ For all my life ♪
(car engine screeches)
♪ When you're with me,
baby the skies'll be blue ♪